>> Laura: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH TONIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATS THREW AROUND A LOT
OF PROVOCATION, WE DON'T WANT TO
SAY LIES, BUT HOUSE INTO WELSH
CHAIR ADAM SCHIFF, HE REALLY
STUMPED TO AN OLD DELL MIKE NEU
LOW BY CLOSING THE HEARING WITH
THIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT PRAISES THE
CORRUPT, HE PRAISES THE CORRUPT.
HE CONDEMNS THE JUST.
YOU PAID AND THEN HE ASKS FOR AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE BIDENS.
THERE IS NO CAMOUFLAGING THAT
CORRUPT INTENT.
WE ARE ADJOURNED.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN, YOU DISPARAGED
THOSE MEMBERS ON THE SIDE OF THE
ISLE THAT WE SHOULD HAVE A
CHANCE TO RESPOND TO YOUR
REMARKS.
THE ONE JOINING ME NOW,
CONGRESSMAN LEE ZELDIN AND HOUS
HOUSE --
CONGRESS MEN, WE SAID ALL ALONG
THAT THIS WAS IMPEACHMENT BY
EMOTION, IT WAS A THEATRICAL
PRODUCTION, AND FELL FLAT AND
GOT TERRIBLE REVIEWS ON DAY ONE.
THEY KNEW THEY TRIED STOMACH HAD
TO TRY TO BRING THE DRAMA SO
IT'S LIKE BEGGING FOR APPLAUSE.
WHAT WAS THAT MOMENT LIKE?
>> I WAS THERE AND THEY HEARING
ALL DAY TODAY AS I WAS ALL DAY
ON WEDNESDAY.
AFTERWARDS WE WENT BACK INTO THE
BUNKER IN THE CAPITAL BASEMENT
AND WENT RIGHT BACK TO THE
DEPOSITION THAT TOOK PLACE THIS
AFTERNOON AND WE ARE BACK THERE
AND I BUNKER TOMORROW AND --
>> Laura: HAUS ABOUT THE
MOMENT WITH THE ELEVATION.
>> THEY FILLED OUT THE CROWD
WITH ALL OF THEIR SUPPORT --
>> Laura: WHY ARE YOU GUYS NOT
DOING THAT?
>> WELL, IT THERE IS A LOT OF
EFFORT ON THE PART OF DEMOCRATS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE ENTIRE
DAY TO MAKE SOMETHING OUT OF
WHAT WAS AT BEST A DRAW FOR
THEM.
THE FACT IS THAT THERE IS
NOTHING NEW TO LEARN.
NOT ONLY DID THEY LEAK OUT THE
BEST OF WHAT OF WHAT YOVANOVITCH
WOULD'VE SAID WHEN SHE GAVE HER
DEPOSITION IN THIS GIFT, THEY
SPUN IT IN A WAY TO SET THE
HIGHER EXPECTATIONS SO IT WAS
ACTUALLY WORSE IF YOU ARE
WATCHING AT HOME OVER THE COURSE
OF TODAY.
NOT ONLY DID YOU NOT LEARN
ANYTHING NEW BUT YOU REALIZED
WITH THE MEDIA WAS TELLING YOU
ABOUT WHAT YOVANOVITCH WAS GOING
TO HAVE TO SAY WASN'T THERE.
SHE WAS OUT OF THE POSITION.
SHE HAD NO OWNER FIRST-HAND
KNOWLEDGE.
SUE AND SHE SAID SHE LOST HER
JOB YOU'RE WELCOME TO THE WORLD.
CIVIL SERVANTS DON'T SERVE
FOREVER.
THE PRESIDENT CAN TAKE HIS
AMBASSADOR.
SHE HAD A GREAT JOB IN
GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT SHE
WANTED.
SHE GOT THE POSITION SHE WANTED.
MY BACKGROUND AS A MILITARY AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE CAN
PICK YOU UP AND MOVE YOU SEVERAL
TIMES.
A SALUTE AND DRIVE ON.
>> Laura: COURTESY OF THE U.S.
TAX THEY ARE, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THE PRESIDENT THINKS.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU,
PRESIDENT SCHIFF ASKS
YOVANOVITCH ABOUT THE
INTIMIDATION.
>> DESERVES HIS ATTACK TO YOU ON
TWITTER --
I READ PART OF HIS TWEETS.
EVERYWHERE WERE YOVANOVITCH
WINCH TURNED A BAD GRADE SHE
STARTED OFF IN SOMALIA.
HOW DID THAT GO?
HE GOES ON TO SAY LATER IN THAT
SWEET THAT ITS U.S. PRESIDENT'S
ABSOLUTELY AND POINT INVESTORS.
THE PRESIDENT IN REAL TIME IS
ATTACKING YOU.
>> IT'S VERY INTIMIDATING.
>> SCHIFF IS SUCH A FRAUD.
THE PRESIDENT PUTS OUT THIS
ENTIRE TWEET AND SCHIFF GIVES
HIS OWN RENDITION OF THE TWEET.
IF YOU WANT TO ASK THE WITNESS
FOR HER FEELINGS ON THE TWEED
AND ASK HER FEELINGS ABOUT
EVERYTHING ELSE, LET HER READ
THE ENTIRE TWEET FOR HERSELF AND
THEN ASK HER A QUESTION BUT FOR
EXAMPLE, THE SECOND PART OF THAT
TWEET WHICH WAS A LITTLE OF THE
LEGITIMATE POINT THAT THEY LEFT
OUT, THEY TRADE PICKED OUT, THE
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JUL5
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JULH
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JULC
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JULL
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JULT
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JULA
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JULS
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JULR
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JULP
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JUL,
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JULT
PRESIDENT NOTICED THIS, THE JULE
RESPONSE FROM PRESIDENT ZELENSKY
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP,
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY CALLS
INVESTOR YOVANOVITCH OF THAT --
ZERO.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY SAYS HE
BELIEVES THAT INVESTOR
YOVANOVITCH HAD LOYALTY TO
PRESIDENT OR SHANK SO WHY DON'T
YOU JUST ALLOW AMBASSADOR
YOVANOVITCH TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION?
>> Laura: AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, IF HE'S
INTIMIDATING, WHY IS HE READING
A QUESTION MARK >> YOVANOVITCH
HAD NO IDEA EXACTLY.
SHE HAD NO IDEA THE TWEED EVEN
EXISTED.
TALK ABOUT WITNESS GAGGING, NOT
ALLOWING SEVERAL PUBLIC
WITNESSES OR WITNESS POACHING AS
WE SAW WITH ATTENDANT CURL THAN
MEN.
HE NEEDS TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
HE DOES EVERYTHING HE ACCUSES
OTHERS.
>> Laura: WHAT DID YOU FEEL
ABOUT THE WAY HE TREATED STEFON
A QUESTION MARK >> HE DOES NOT
LIKE A LEAST A PHONIC AND SHE
HAS BEEN A STRONG WOMAN, SHE
DOES HER HOMEWORK, SHE'S BEEN
WORKING HARD, SHE'S PREPARING
FOR ALL OF THESE
TESTIMONIES, SHE'S BEEN
FANTASTIC AND SCHIFF STATES
THAT.
>> Laura: ON THE OFFICIAL WHO
WAS GOING TO END TEST TESTIFY
AND GIVE A DEPOSITION EVEN ON
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS NO GREAT >>
HE IS EXPECTED TO COME AND HE'S
BEEN ANSWERING QUESTIONS WITH
REGARDS TO THE HOLD ON A BUT
KEEP IN MIND, UKRAINE DID NOT
KNOW ABOUT THE HOLD ON EIGHT
UNTIL AUGUST.
IT GETS RELEASED SHORTLY
THEREAFTER AND GUESS WHAT
UKRAINE HAS TO DO IN ORDER TO A